serious question I like the last Jedi
but was that movie even a sequel to the
force awakens
like did Snoke matter at all what
happened to the Knights of Ren is that
even a thing
wasn't kylo Ren obsessed with Darth
Vader
where'd c-3po spread arm go
I wasn't pohe for Finn anymore that
embrace was amazing because his mouth
didn't Luke leave his friends to go find
the first Jedi Temple he's good of that
least told them why he was leaving right
go away if he just wanted a place to die
he could go literally anywhere or just
die did the last gen I break space
combat when Hollow accelerates to
hyperspace through that Star Destroyer
why doesn't everyone do that why bother
building a Death Star if they do just
fire a bunch of hyperspace logs through
it right and have a droid flip the
switch she didn't need to go down with
the ship did she don't how has no one
ever thought to do this did they all
sign a truce not two what's this a war
crime star probably because the
resistance is broke hyperdrives ain't
cheap yo just saw some more decoder
rings and on the other side they found
us
if the first order can track the
resistance through hyperspace why not
make a jump to a safe distance than
another jump to right in front of them
boom does this mean we're going to have
to start thinking about other dumb real
science problems from Star Wars I don't
actually care about like why are there
explosions in space for sounds or bombs
that fall straight down
does the fact that it all looks badass
make everything okay
it does doesn't it Star Trek what was up
at that Maz Kanata video chat scene
who's filming is she a vlogger now does
she buy a GoPro droid with insurance
money after her castle bar blew up
streaming live on Twitch with Drake
what's up with her shooting guns in some
kind of union dispute is Maz Kanata a
union busting scab or is she shooting at
her old employees cuz they asked for
higher pay or is the first orders first
order of business cracking down on
organized labor they're not Republicans
then in that same video call
she implies she had sex with the
codebreaker really how's that work she
called Chewbacca her boyfriend - where's
my boyfriend
chewies working on the Falcon his mom's
just being cheeky or like does she get
down how much alien species
interbreeding happens in the Star Wars
universe is it just Han and Chewie
should I google any of this probably not
right Maz Kanata all right jumping and
forced ghosts and lightning how many
force powers are there now I mean that
force projection thing that Luke does at
the end really is kind of a stretch but
he seemed fine when Rey left but because
he used the force really hard he died so
do all Jedi die if they use the force
too hard
is there a cautionary tale about lifting
a certain number of rocks or you'll just
keel over do or do not because you might
die I mean if you can force so hard that
you die does that mean like all the
other Jedi from the movies were phoning
it in and sure ryan johnson got that
power out of a book that was published a
long time ago but does that mean that
all the other force powers in that book
are fair game because if so are we gonna
see a Jedi's shrink to the size of an
atom
manikin can sip really kill people just
by looking at them really hard actually
that does sound kind of cool okay dude
either Johnson doesn't know the law or
he knows too much big one
what does poor taste like I could go for
a pork chop okay we're done
subscribe
[Music]
you